[Musique]
ai-je en plein travail
et oui voyez catherine bonsoir bonsoir
est ce qu'on dit toute la vérité ce soir
dit que tout avait été calculée qualité
s'est inclinée ce cap pour vous voyez
oui c'est acquis ce que vous entendez
peut-être un petit peu quand par l'image
qui est peut être un petit peu moins
belle qu'elle n'est elle pas déjà une
émission en direct alors ce qui laisse
com va vous permettre ray man et de
réaliser un plat qui ne se fait pas en
22 minutes
il faut un tout petit peu plus de temps
pour le réaliser alors nous allons
pouvoir jouer justement c'était 27
minutes à quoi vous avez droit à dix
pendant quelques instants
on sent on vous laissera le temps de la
cuisson et puis reviendra mais en
réalité pour vous ce sera la même chose
alors je vous avais une bouffe chose
réuni beaucoup de choses que faire ce
risotto
c'est un genre de risotto d'ailleurs
d'ouvrir immédiatement ici de lui dans
cette huile demi du lard et dans ceux là
je viens de mettre de la poitrine de
porc c'est à dire du port non tu mets du
portrait le couple est alors là je vais
te couper en troubles et en dessous
petit poulet vous allez voir que les
quasi pétrole ce poste pour lui personne
ne serait bien non sans donner le nombre
de choses il y en a dedans il est ouvert
du 6 vous guider
réalisez la recette pour 4 personnes et
l'on était lui parce qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses à mettre déjà du lard
déjà dû travers de porc et maintenant
vous un collet alors si vous voulez
aussi les séries sol et sa nonchalance
pendant quelques secondes
que voulez vous les blancs voient la
semaine depuis vingt six ans alors la
voyait au 200 m un verre environ pas
plus et puis vous avez vous donné les
coquillages qui sont à côté des
langoustines à lourdes
alors nous allons prendre les trois
jours les coptes voulez vous approcher
un peu de moi merci pour tes limites si
les métiers dans du vin blanc pourrait
rouvrir simplement renvoyé au soir vous
voyez là on fait un nom autre chose on
n'est pas les langoustines 29 celle en
autonomie totale espagnole
ça fait environ une livre soit on va
recourir cela se passe au fort alors je
reviens à mon poulet que j'avais avant
des quais seconde lâchement je remets
ici en plein feu et je mets les vents se
fout les coûts perceptible a pu voir
rouler environ
non non seulement vous n'êtes pas
laisser aller votre petit penchant cello
j'allais oublier vous faire un petit mot
non seulement un petit morceau mais
peut-être aussi un petit poulet c'était
tout de même important à mentionner et
je vais encore ajouté s'ils voulaient
bien un peu d'huile d'olive 2010 parce
qu'ils pensent que nous allons mettre
des petits oignons et ont joué en met
environ 24 24 étudiants
la jeune est remonté vers nîmes le met
très vite à l'ère lyonnaise un petit peu
d'échalotes de n'être delahaye joyau de
la viande en brousse par deux bogeys en
saut
léo voilà qu'on nous donne roulage
téléchargement réseau fils et moi je
vais mettre 4 échalotes
parce que les oignons donc d'abord les
oignons nous restait entier c'est
important les gousses d'ail ou encore ce
qui est également important et les chats
l'autre elle ne se crée ne faudrait pas
alors je préfère qu à couper face à ce
qu'on la retrouve pas ensuite c'est à
dire que la voyais ce niveau et cela
alors je pense que l'on fera nécessité
aussi de couper un petit peu peau
pendant peu de temps le temps que ça
arrive sur les voilà à l'orgue ajouté
qu'alors je même ajouté un oignon que je
vais couper également en morceaux cas là
il va donner du goût au début tandis que
les petits oignons e on restait entier
une au nom de votre petit à petit alors
important mais dites-moi est-ce que ça
n'a pas une parenté avec apple
oh oui ça n'a eu bien sûr mais dans la
façon de faire c'est tout à fait
différent
le résultat laisse que l' on la
retrouvera dans un plat service on ne
savait pas la méthode d'exécution et
pourrait y avoir de parenté est évidente
ça c'est d'inspiration cette inspiration
espagnol à l'exécution mais l'exécution
est tout à fait différente d'hier nos
bords alors ici hoyé oh ça va très bien
dans l'essai à oui j'avais deux grands
pères qui s'appelait tous les deux
guillon nocives et moi aussi parce que
c'est la tradition voulait que cette
famille incertaine
sur dix autos guillermo c'est le risotto
de mon grand père d'ailleurs tel qu'ils
le pont serait lui même
alors ici voyez vous je prépare des
piments des piments doux détriment du
tube de morrone c'est à dire des
poivrons et jeu en coupe et 8 ne pas se
dire on passe quelque chose
j'enlève les graines s'il y en a parce
que les grains c'est tout de même un peu
fort ne roule en l'occurrence ya pas
beaucoup de grèves
il leur est aussi un petit peu de jambon
de bayonne et je peux tout ça dans la
même cocotte tout seul dans la même
pourquoi croyez vous évidemment la peña
se fait dans une poêle et le poivre se
fait dans une grande poêle et alors on
met les éléments les ans présent on met
le riz et on soupe ou dhr avec l'eau à
faire on jette l'eau dessus
en fait il ya un peu plus léger c'est
plus compliqué faute une installation
pour faire une faille à nous n'avons pas
non plus alors ici alors continuez à
donner la couleur est assez peu importe
henriot ce démarrage est très important
il doit avoir lieu avec le maximum de
chaleur il faut que ça prenne couleurs
le plus vite possible alors nous avons
parlé devant une vaillante mais il ne
s'agit pas de mettre des belles tranches
il s'agit de se servir voyez-vous d'une
crosse ou d'un morceau actuellement
chacun a pas chez soi une mode mais on
peut toujours géant - c'est ça avoir en
petits morceaux comme je voulais voir
plusieurs fois on achète on dans ce
charmant et on la joue
sa part excusez moi avec ce nouvel an
les et complétant disait pas du tout
part de là et puis on a coupé dans
l'autre sens j'ai enlevé le mot ce qui a
touché la cendre que ce qu'à push et
extérieur et il vaut mieux ne pas le
mettre dans la crise sont vraiment
débarrasser merci en tout petits
morceaux qui vont fondre le plus
possible dans la préparation
vous voyez tout ça ça va très bien alors
on va mesurer maintenant quand je vois
que vous avez encore à tout et vous le
savez sourisseau ah oui tout à l'heure
on a fait une méthode aussi celle là et
ça c'est très personnel je pense que le
chorizo dans la danse et des
préparations du genre aussi bien
d'ailleurs dans la peña que dans les
risottos sallaumines beaucoup trop alors
il faut remettre si on veut point de vue
des corps mais pas tellement au point du
goût
alors j'ai une méthode à moi employés
lario ici ça va bien ça va
petit hic de chorizo inouïe
nos méthodes moi je leur ai envoyé les
choristes sont bons alors ici tout ça va
bien je vais passer maintenant au riz
alors le ring le voilà vous savez que
les temps de cuisson nourrice alors je
vais le mesurer voyez là il ne livre à
peu près et je vais mettre deux fois la
quantité
le volume les volumes d'eau pour le
volume de riz un peu plus haut
voilà un tout petit peu plus dauphin n'a
que je vais m'occuper des bonzes est pas
gentil avec le caméraman avaient passé
pour filer d'un flux à l'autre ah oui on
croyait catherine lancez-vous là
attendez vous passez du feuilleton ceci
étant terminée je vous en vain 15 autres
démembrements
eh bien eh bien j'aimerais pouvoir les
retirer les maîtres ici pour les
décortiquer tout à l'heure qu'est ce
qu'ils ont ils sont un petit peu froid
elle veut juste parce que vous pourriez
imposer quelque part sans que cela vous
gêne à donc ça s'est terminé le si
j'avais quelque chose à faire je
voudrais décortiqué langoustines c'est
ça alors pendant que savard refroidir
quelques secondes alors je m'en avait
décortiqué la bottine c'était simplement
la preuve on peut les mettre entière
n'est ce pas rien ne s'y oppose
mais en l'occurrence je pense que ça
prend beaucoup de place pour rien alors
je le mettrais que les queues de
langoustines russes se sont en effet air
de ceux ci et je voudrais le maître par
ici dans un serviront tout à l'heure
alors ici hall et le reste ça n'a pas
d'importance on peut en faire une petite
bise qu'on peut en faire un portage on
peut
oh non c'est cru avec ses cris on sait
qu on se fasse pas du vrai gaspillage
non voilà alors ici nous alors mettre
les queues de langoustines disposant la
voulez vous avoir la gentillesse de
débarrasser de ceux ci voilà et puis
nous allons ici
ajouter le riz alors voilà le riz je
vais prendre de l'eau chaude ou que ça
aille plus vite
je vais l'apprendre tout à l'heure je
vais d'abord laissé prendre couleur ou
non c'est le choix parce que toujours
m'enlever
c'est une question de temps de parcours
bon et bien ici je n'en avais préparé
les là je voudrais deux nations unies 6
1 et 6 1 pour le moment où je laisse la
moitié c'est-à-dire un demi
voilà alors ceci ce peintre cathy vieux
mas est tout de même le père est alors
qu'on passera la cuisson qui fait partie
du mouvement de notre place dans ce cas
là on les ouvre comme ça ce respect bien
faire d'ailleurs beaucoup pas nier la
volonté votre attention
on rire parce qu'ils ne brûlent pas pour
et c'est suffisant maintenant je vais
mouiller alors je vais mouiller vous
désirez de deux fois la quantité de
s'achever
alors je mélange les coudes et oui mais
d'abord je vais mélanger
voilà qui est fait je vais mettre le
bouquet garni
je vais mettre les queues de
langoustines si vous voulez dire désolé
c'est maintenant je vais les mettre
aussi mais j'ai encore quelques secondes
je vais donc en profiter j'avais salez
et poivrez
je peux émettre également venu pis si je
veux voilà le pois radis noir dans la
cabine france récupère le couvercle et
je vais mettre ceci ou le mans sur un
feu doux
on a quelques secondes le temps que je
finisse avec mes coquillages ainsi tôt
on va couvrir béarnais secundo on peut
courir avec le volet alors vous allez me
prête donner une anti georges blanc la
propre famille prix là vous le maître et
ci-dessus comme ceux ci un émissaire
parce que nous allons passer la
commission de ces coquillages chinois
non le financent pas suffisant ça
laisserait passer le sable
la save et immédiatement la ajouté la
voilà je vais la récupérer type même pas
oui oui alors nous allons mettre tous
ces coquillages
décortiquée dans la coop
si j'ai des bâtiments logistiques ça va
très bien voilà alors je vais les mettre
voyez vous je vais du tout les mêmes en
réalité dans le plat je marie ajouté la
cuisson des moules ou alors pour dire
que je les mettrai tous en réalité tout
à l'heure on a quelques secondes que
mettre tous mes biens côté de la
coquille avec un côté ma coquille et
puis je me rêvais hêtre cela au four
pendant environ 1 carte par le niveau
pendant un quart d'heure vrai voilà et
bien maintenant nous allons attendre un
quart d'heure et bien maintenant il faut
un quart d'heure de cuisson au risotto
mais voilà
qui vous ont probablement par une courte
mais en fait qu'ils sont vraiment pour
nous puisque encore une fois il s'agit
d'un kiné scop alors 15 minutes ça y est
c'est cuit répond ah ben non c'est pas
tout à fait critiquable
oui presque je peux le sortir du four
vous avez pu gagner 15 minutes puis
merveilleusement sur feu doux et puis
maintenant nous occuper maintenant
d'autres choses nous allons occuper de
faire d'abord on va couper le chorizo
parce que vous aviez l'air d'aimer le
chorizo alors coupé bayrou en rondelles
comme ceux ci pas trop fine où elle pas
trop fine et vous allez mettre à cuire
on le mettra qu est dans de l'eau dans
de l'eau ni salé ni poivrer c'est
suffisant ou sottement comme ça voilà
dans de l'eau qui et comment la l1 le
cours est en ébullition c'est un non dit
combien alors on le temps que nous
allons en sus dans leurs discours alors
ici les couper de petites atteint et le
coût d'un couteau plus gros ça peux pas
vous dire parce que ça fait encore
décidée petit café d'agneau rappelleront
alors je crois que l'on vous pouvez dire
à 4 nous pourrions dès que si nous
n'avons pas tout on peut néanmoins
réalisé avec un élément - justement le
fait qu'ils aient beaucoup d'éléments
permet d'investissement compris sans
oublier quelques mois je vais enlever ce
petit bout d'os qui me gêne la
valaisanne
vous avez pris deux petites qu'en
principe à peu près deux petites côtes
est parfait et environ une ou deux
voilà et puis
je vais un peu d'huile quatrième jeu
vous pouvez encore toujours de l'huile
d'olive bien sûr alors un tout petit peu
d'huile comme ceci dans une assiette
dans l'assiette
je m'en vais aller me côté des
côtelettes de quoi vous allez me dire
comment je vais les faire griller ou
green alors car le grill carrément aller
passer un tout petit peu comme ceci dit
je vous pose une question pourquoi
gestion laisser la cocotte au four
encore pendantes normal que maintenant
je les ai mises à reposer en quelque
sorte et alliés j'ai enlevé le grande
partie de la chaleur autour serait était
trop tôt là je pense que ça sera très
bien ça montre voilà alors un quart
d'heure d'ébullition violent ça a été
très bien non voilà
c'est du championnat les petits pour la
table alors les mains papauté au regard
de la france ah oui c'est toujours qui
vit là j'ai des petites choses on
économise terme en continuant la
vendange est alors là je vais le clic
est un petit peu comme ceux ci s'élèvent
maintenant à griller à côté des
toilettes
voilà alors nous allons pouvoir sait que
ça va être plus tard le temps que nous
allions nous adresser préparer le plat
de présenter la musique et joie non lieu
de piquer les clients la taille réduite
personnes de 4,6 selon m restée jeune
moine mais il n'y a pas de place tout
cela c'est pour ça vaille et a failli
arrêter pas de réponse on n'a pas réussi
voilà l'une des consoles enterrement
anticipé la tâche compliquée policiers
en est ainsi je vais retourner
c'est vraiment ce n'est pas la grosseur
ce que l'on préfère oui c'est très joli
pour le décor alors bonnes il faut pas
trop néanmoins voilà là je ne peux pas
pour abandonner cette cuisson car ça va
relativement très largement avait passé
segré sur un peu moins violent
maintenant ça veut dire vous allez vous
déplacer vous déplacer en mouvement
aller vers ça c'est vraiment son aval
vous prêts
voilà je vais continuer la cuisson ici
alors là c'est fini ici je vais vérifier
l'évolution kilisho épisode ça va très
bien alors je voudrais ce remplaçant
voilà vous enlevez les couteaux casting
c'est fini nous n'avons plus maintenant
car nous occuper de décor alors voici un
mois vous allez sortir je crois que nous
pourrions peut-être peut-être bien
rencontrer si le téléspectateur de
l'écrit nous allons leur en donnait
alors vers le pire
voyez aussi bien mélanger sanaa le tout
mais oui tu apprennes à meerab le mans
depuis sont dit oui alors vous savez que
le riz mais environ 20 minutes a fait
mais qu'il faut le laisser reposer
environ cinq minutes après que c'était
un minutes ce n'était pas pat et de la
cuisson or du peu mais carrément ça vous
voulez bien me dire ce qu'il faut pour
cela attendre je voudrais verizon je
voudrais d'abord si vous voulez bien
nous montrer je leur apprends finir un
verre wayoro katherine voudrait mettre
tous leurs oeufs bien vide et je
voudrais qu'on puisse tenir de façon que
nous lisions ensemble attendez je
voudrais que finiens quand même monsieur
on avale oct ans avec après je voudrais
finir il a la boule un type ou les jeux
les ajouter en exergue oui roger petit
poulain du las des moules ce que cache
un travers le car est pas vous avez dit
c'est hélas parti qui était au dessus
des côtes est c'est ça oui de petits
oignons et puis de leila bien des
échalotes 1 bouquet garni de l'huile
d'olive il n'en faut pas mal aussi tout
de même la peau pour cela il faut pas
loin d'un quart de litre
vous l'avez en 2008 oui après pas tout à
fait un cadeau mi temps 10 heures et si
on en prend un coup mais chipolatas une
personne un peu près des petites
côtelettes d'agneau les haies brise du
sel du poivre
et puis des poivrons des gens petit peu
de vin blanc voilà villa rococo
alors voyez de toute façon nous
rappelons tout ça dans télé 59,6 par
hasard quelque chose a échappé avec les
spectacles en ce moment si c'est ça
c'est pour la partie
alors là voyez je m'en vais récupérer le
jus de cuisson car s'agit d'un taré
volet des crises on n'en avait le verser
sur mon petit risotto vous voulez dire
que tous un très bon c'est pas que pour
la décoration c'est jean-louis site
attendait bien encore le chorizo parce
que je mène voyez je verse ici le jus
oui j'avoue diriger le chorizo gère
largement c'est d'une minute catherine
j'avais âgées que moi quelqu'un m'a volé
mon écrit moi c'est très mal de votre
temps
j'ai rien prises dans les bouges espoirs
sûrement pas seraient 400 pixels et
c'est moi qui l'ait laissée dans la dans
la cocotte dans les communs en arrivant
[Musique]
les besoins et bien maintenant l'eau de
cuisson
absolument rien alors là on peut
également indisposées gentiment et bien
je pense qu'il faut pas oublier les
temps de cuisson
il ne faut pas oublier de tous les
séries seraient ensemble y compris le
riz de mouiller deux fois environ
jeudi environ parce qu'en réalité nous
avons mouillé un tout petit peu plus
puisque nous avons ajouté la cuisson des
moules et coquillages
c'est peu de chose deux fois largement
et puis assaisonnez assez dingue ou pas
trop parce que l'eau des copieurs et
salé par conséquent tenir compte dans le
la façon de salé et mon dieu il ya aussi
des éléments qui peuvent être vraies ce
qui n'est pas le cas ici alors on peut
toujours aussi faire attention pour ne
pas trop en mettre
et puis après si l'on veut on peut
saupoudrer avec des financeurs et alors
la justice tombe bien c'est le risotto
vraiment l'hiver guillermo tout ce qu'on
voudra ne nous dit pas moi le risotto je
le fais pas comme ça moi c'est ça c'est
ça c'est une recette c'est une merci
léman et non cette amusante et bon comme
d'habitude je pense qu'il est l'heure
maintenant de votre repas lors de
l'happy
[Musique]